[Music]
what do the uk's national parks really
look like
to see what these landscapes are made up
of let's go on a walk
each second of the walk reveals one
percent of our national parks
and how they appear from above are you
ready for the uk's national parks in 100
seconds
the first 20 kinds of land are gone in a
blink
six seconds and six percent of our walk
is through crops peat bugs
are large stores of water and carbon
and are home to special wetland wildlife
they cover 12 of our national parks
the next 14 seconds of our journey we
can get lost in the woods
and for half that time we pass through
coniferous forests
most have been planted by people
we spend 15 seconds crossing natural and
semi-natural grasslands scarce in the uk
they have the potential to provide homes
for a rich variety of plants and animals
[Music]
we explore heaths and moors for 22
seconds of our walk
stepping over heather bilbrey cowberry
and crowberry plants
look carefully can you see a deer or a
hair
much of this land is managed for
shooting birds
through a combination of cutting grazing
and burning
large parts of our national parks are
agricultural lands
supporting the people livelihoods and
cultures that maintain the landscape
our final 24 seconds is through pastures
which are mostly used for
rearing cows and sheep our national
parks were created to conserve and
enhance their wildlife
beauty heritage and use there for all of
us to enjoy
care for and benefit from
so reflecting on what they look like and
the challenges we face
what could we do to make the most of our
national parks
what do you think